miriah you look like you are in your
christmas glory i love this is this part
of the set for the special
actually no
the sap special is a lot more elaborate
but this is part of just
us getting into the christmas spirit now
i know we're early kevin i'm not saying
we're not early we gotta get through
thanksgiving first and i know this but
when i started i made my first christmas
album and i was traveling the world and
i'm like wow they're really into
christmas early late because there's no
thanksgiving they don't have
thanksgiving
so you know that would be our american
thing
you know all right so tell me about this
show because you have great special
guests you're going to sing some of your
songs by the way all i want for
christmas is almost 30 years old
[Music]
first of all i rebuke you because i
don't know numbers okay kevin stop
trying to age me you go talk about what
you were doing 30 years ago okay now i'm
only kidding
you look amazing right now let me just
say that
thank you
30 years because they've done something
really good to you oh i love you no
really honestly
it's bizarre like so when i first wrote
all i went for christmas is you the
label was like okay why don't you do a
christmas record
sony and i'm like really now like second
album like two albums in
and and then i was like well i do love
the holidays let me try so all i want
for christmas is you was the first song
i wrote first christmas song that i ever
wrote and you know then i worked on it
with my then writing partner walter a
and we just wanted to make it feel like
a modern classic so it wasn't like oh
this is this era you know what i mean so
when i see it like the other day
somebody sent me a video of people in a
club like young people in a club like
jumping up and down flipping out
screaming dancing the dj's cutting the
record out and they're like oh i want it
was like it makes me so happy because i
am festive i do love the holidays of
course you know you and i know that
we've spoken about my other projects my
other work
books this and that by the way my
paperback is out i need you to get it
because it's got my little girl self on
the cover and i've been going back and
forth with lee daniels driving him crazy
he's driving me crazy we're figuring out
the adaptation for the media what are
you gonna do are you going to make oh
yes
it's more than a movie right now like
we're dealing with lee yeah
we're dealing we're dealing with lee so
it's it's got to be gritty and real and
all the things that are not this moment
you know what i mean but it has to also
have these moments you know so big daddy
we call them yesterday i got the call
from big daddy because you know i'm just
whatever i can't give away all my secret
to lee he's gonna kill me you know he is
big daddy i can't but i'm saying there's
stuff coming up next year that is just
like beyond exciting for me and there's
other musical things i've been working
on a project called the butterfly lounge
where we actually recorded this yeah
this duet for the apple tv plus special
with khalid and kirk franklin
called fall in love at christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
hey hold up and and brian helped you
direct it yes he did ryan tanaka i call
him tanaka but yeah he did i help you
directly yes and bill boatman king of
lighting and king of
all many things he's drinking black
irish right now which is my new liquor
that you need to be trying why have they
not sent this to you kevin i don't
understand and you tell bill i said
what's up
i know but no no really this black irish
situation it's a moment and it's salted
caramel regular like original irish
cream and then um
white chocolate and you can make like so
many drinks with this thing what are you
doing with them babies for chris how do
they enjoy christmas and what are you
going to do with them oh my gosh
if them babies don't enjoy christmas i
don't know who does okay i spend the
whole year figuring it out and you know
look they do enjoy christmas we ski they
go i mean we ski they ski i take one run
down the mountain and i'm good but they
snowboard they do everything they i mean
like look whatever you want to say oh
can you see this can you see this here
let me see my little blankie
and yeah and this is out this year like
it's got the puppies and there's your
real puppy cha-cha
there's my little plushy girl oh oh here
comes molly yes molly come here it's
kevin
oh there he goes there we go oh yeah
he's kind of he's kind of clunky but
anyway we're all here we have the best
time of christmas we go to aspen every
year we it has to snow like even the
thing i love about that is that even if
it doesn't snow you're literally looking
at mountains with snow on them so you
know i am i and and like we were talking
about the book and if i can be try to be
semi-serious for a second in my memoir i
talk about
how when i was a little kid growing up
with no money
growing up being mixed not understanding
having you know ra identity issues all
the things and then that
going through my my career and stuff and
all the different things that have
happened that i never really talked
about to even some of my best friends
the thing is when i wrote about
christmas i was like oh wait i don't
want to bring people down because
there's some like depressing stuff that
happened but the reason but that's the
reason that it motivated me to really go
all the way in every christmas every
year and i just want my kids to have the
best time
and
honestly it's like a lot of it is for me
okay so let me ask you this will any of
their stepbrothers or stepsisters ever
get to enjoy christmas your way because
it's a special way is it step i don't
think it's step it's it's not
if you're not married to the person i
don't know about that that's a
difference that's a different interview
for you
i hear you mariah i hear you
[Music]
[Music]
hey tell me about
kurt franklin
and also khalid having them on your
special how was that that was incredible
first of all just writing the song
um in the butterfly lounge as i was
mentioning we started in atlanta because
my band was there and during covid we're
not traveling we're not you know putting
on shows we're not in vegas
but i got a chance to really really
really heal my voice and get to a place
where you know we were writing every
other day the band was coming over we
filmed this so i'm hoping this becomes
and actually been having conversations
its own um
like a streaming moment
separate and apart from any other like
you know adaptation and that stuff but
so there's that and we wrote a christmas
song daniel moore and myself i work with
he my band uh he directs my band he's an
amazing musician and we laid it out and
and then it was like khalid i've loved
khalid since since location and i told
him that when i met him and i was like
american teen was one of my favorite
albums and you know because i'm
eternally 12. so i was like oh my gosh i
live for this so you know daniel did a
little a little uh he laid out some
things and kali did his own
interpretation of that and then
kirk
daniel had just done the stellar awards
and been with every gospel artist in the
world basically and um so he's like you
know i hope you don't mind i mentioned
something to kirk i'm like what
so kirk came to atlanta through the
butterfly lounge um we wrote that outro
together i don't know if you've heard
the song yet but it goes to church at
the end so yes you start very simple
very
simple love song christmas melancholy
and then you're like i said we pray it's
a moment so you bring that voice you
bring you like all of a sudden when you
hear you shifting gears and it's like oh
wow we're ready everybody wants to stand
up in the pew
[Laughter]
no it really was an amazing and you know
kirk is a gospel legend and he's humble
about it you know uh i know we wouldn't
say humble
with him because when we really know him
he's festive he's fun he's amazing we
had the best time but i love the video
because i love there's a certain shot of
him where the snow is coming down and
it's just it's just kirk like saying
like more than now more than ever we
need to let you know we need to give
love away like he's really giving you a
message at that point you know what i'm
saying and that made me really feel
good about it because i i live for all i
want for christmas as you i've i've
grown to love it as the writer i've
grown to love it more because i used to
just grown to love it how can't you love
that that song makes you happy i'm being
honest you're whether you're walking in
the mall whether you're going driving in
your car whether you're arguing with
your wife whether your kids are acting
bad the song makes you happy so how can
you how did you have to grow to love it
i had to learn how to let myself
like live with mistakes that i would
have changed and stuff like that but now
i love it it's part of my life i feel
like i grew up with it and share it with
the world and hopefully you'll listen to
it this year call us on thanksgiving if
you're bored
and uh merry christmas
[Music]